this this is what sim is all about old
sexist horny men and poop jokes our
society is really making advances bad
grandpa this is quite an interesting
film some might say to me Ryan right
it's interesting the right word to
describe this movie after all you are
Ryan right so you must always be right
right but honestly I walked into this
film going it's decent but when I
thought about it the word that comes to
mind is interesting and the movie
suddenly got even better it's like a
less energetic version of Borat but
instead you get like a bad grandpa who's
taking his grandson across the country
to meet up with his father so we can
give him away here's that the take care
of the little [ __ ] his words not mine I
will admit I had difficulty getting into
the movie at first isn't the opening
credits that had three writers so I
found myself distracted trying to figure
out which bids might have been you know
scripted which bits were all actors and
then which bits are actually real and I
was like very much used to it just being
a a prank skit in the Jackass movies
which made me had difficulty adjusting
to the fact that this is actually a
storyline but after a while you know
some good things start to happen you
start to realize this film has a heart
you start asking yourself how bad is our
bad grandpa really he's pretty bad
johnny Knoxville he just brings this
character to life it's so apparent why
people are able to be fooled by this guy
this old fart it's not just that he has
like great makeup on he transforms so
much into the role that intermittently
you do forget that it's Knoxville under
all this makeup he's incredibly crude
incredibly rude sexist horny although I
gotta say we got a lot in common except
for the one fact that he's able to get
away with all this [ __ ] just because
he's old this movie makes me look
forward to being old with the kind of
[ __ ] I get away with saying now on this
show I can only imagine what I'll get
away with what I'm 89 years old why not
I'll go [ __ ] a vending machine probably
worse stuff than him when i'm older i
could start up my reality show called
dick in your face it's exactly what it
sounds like that's where we take hidden
cameras flying celebrities and then bam
i whack my dick in their face
ie I run its a Brad Pitt while he's
walking around Angelina Jolie and one of
his like 19 children and he's holding
hands with his Chinese kid and then I
come in running out of nowhere and then
what just happened damn i hit my dick in
his face and I just run the [ __ ] away
and this movie taught me that I will now
be able to do that when I am old so yes
knoxville delivers if you love this kid
in the Jackass movies are gonna go to
like him even more in this phone that's
a fact truth literal penis the real
impressive performer in this film though
has to go to this kid the grandson i
like them so much i looked up his name
on IMDb and then i forgot it while doing
this review the grandson is hilarious
he's totally believable just absolutely
sincere and his crazy dialogue he has to
deliver it makes me wonder if the kid
even knew what he was talking about well
knoxville is more over the top that
really works for this film this kid
balances it with a lot more realism and
his level of commitment to the hidden
camera pranks brilliant if this kid
keeps it up he's gonna be a superstar
when he's older he's gonna be one of the
celebrities wear white my dick on his
face it's worth watching just for the
level of commitment these two performers
have and yes there are some jaw-dropping
shocked moments like the one time I
heard my ex-girlfriend fart which was
then followed by a mysterious erection
but the jaw-dropping moments are not
just shocking they're actually really
funny sometimes just flat-out hilarious
now I didn't buy myself necessarily
entertain like throughout but so many
times when I was like okay this is
getting pretty boring now suddenly
something would happen where I would
just burst in the laughter and I have
one of those like delayed reaction laps
when i'm actually laughing in the
theater it's always like junk haha so it
may not be like consistently funny like
every [ __ ] minute but like every
eight to 12 minutes it's pretty damn
funny it's kind of like hanging out with
a [ __ ] Vietnamese woman that that
has got to be the most [ __ ] up thing
I've said on this show I can feel people
exiting the video as we speak to sum it
up what you got from the trailer and you
hope you will get from the movie it
totally delivers let me get straight to
the point here all
all i gotta say bad grandpa got it right
alright guys thanks are checking out my
review for bad grandpa why don't you go
ahead score that comment box below and
tell me what ridiculous thing are you
gonna get away with than your old EDD
want to go ahead and follow me on
twitter haha follow me and talk about
how shitty i am and if you want see more
in-depth review of bad grandpa going to
check out my show called reasons to see
that I do my buddy Jerry he's in his 20s
but he looks like he could be a bad
grandpa last but not least if you want
to get updated every time one of my
reviews is out going to cooker this
Buttercup my dick to subscribe that's
right click the dick does this little
grandpa he's been bad and he needs to be
punished I know someone to whack my face
on your dick wait